red and purple states gain congressional
seats as blue states lose population
the anti-police movement continues to
gain steam and we discuss the worst
example of woke mob
targeting i've ever seen in my life i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to bigtech protect
your data at expressvpn.com
well before we go any further let me
remind you you're spending hundreds of
dollars too much on your cell phone bill
every single year like way too much
because you could have the same exact
coverage as one of the giant cell phone
companies
and not spend a fortune on those
companies instead why don't you switch
over to pure talk
usa just like thousands of my customers
that's right instead of charging you
obscene fees to pay for their massive
mainstream media campaigns corporate
campuses retail outlets across the
country
puretalk will pass the savings on to you
the average family saves over 800
a year it's a lot of money switching is
super easy i mean really it is it is
really
really really simple you keep your phone
you can keep your number or
you get giant discounts on the latest
iphones and androids we for example got
an iphone 12 at a heavily discounted
price right now
you can get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and here's the thing if you go over on
the data
they are not going to charge you for us
you really have nothing to lose
so instead of taking that one size fits
all plan from a giant cell coverage
provider
charging you hundreds of dollars too
much every year instead check out pure
talk usa by dialing pound 250 and saying
my name ben shapiro you'll save 50
off your first month and hundreds for
the rest of the year that's pound two
five zero say ben
shapiro to get started again dial pound
250 and say my name
ben shapiro to get started with pure
talk usa well before i get to the news
quick announcement about our job
openings here at the dailywear we've got
some exciting news for freedom fighting
creative masterminds out there looking
to join the daily wire at our
headquarters
in nashville tennessee beautiful
nashville if you're a graphic designer
with at least five years of previous
professional graphic design experience
the daily wires mission you know it
you're an idea generating machine you
could be the next
senior graphic designer at the daily
wire that's a pretty big deal guys you
have a heavy hand in our creative
strategy here so if you're up for the
challenge
visit dailywire.com careers send us at
your resume now is your chance to work
for daily wire that's dailywire.com
careers i might just see you around in
nashville okay so the big news of the
day
is that we now have census numbers and
what the census numbers show is that
americans are now
moving they are voting with their feet
they're moving from states like new york
like
california and they are going to places
that are more purple or red
why well because it is better to live in
places that are purple or red as a
recent expatriate
from california to florida let me tell
you florida's better
it is way better and i'm not the only
one because florida just picked up a
congressional seat
thanks to the census bureau texas picked
up a couple of congressional seats
thanks to the census bureau
and by the way that was actually sort of
an underestimate
most people thought that florida was
going to pick up at least two not just
one
but the states that gained are almost
entirely purple or red
and the states that lost are almost
entirely blue the the
sole exception i believe there is
probably ohio which lost a congressional
seat and that is because the rust belt
has been moving a lot into the sun belt
according to the washington post
political power in the united states
will continue
to shift south this decade as
historically democratic states that
border the great lakes give up
congressional seats and electoral votes
to regions where republicans currently
enjoy a political advantage
according to new data from the us census
bureau texas florida north carolina you
wonder why
your corporate media in new york and la
why they
despise texas and florida why they are
constantly ripping on texas and florida
it's because
all of the people who earn money in
these states and have the ability to
move
and don't have their heads so far up
their own rectums it's coming out their
head again
are moving away from new york and
connecticut and new jersey and
california
and they're moving instead to states
where they can actually live comfortable
nice free lives
texas florida and north carolina three
states that voted twice for president
trump are set to gain a combined four
additional seats in congress in 2023
because of population growth
granting them collectively as many new
votes in the electoral college for the
next presidential election
as hawaii has in total so this does
shift some of the electoral college math
not only that it shifts the nature of
the house most political prognosticators
believe that republicans because of that
reapportionment
basically just gained three seats in the
house well democrats are only up by five
or six seats in the house right now so
that means the republicans are already
just thanks to the census bureau on the
verge of retaking the house of
representatives now
that changes based on redistricting in a
lot of these states we know that in new
york for example
there are a bunch of republican seats in
new york new york is going to redistrict
and they're attempting to to get rid of
a lot of those republican seats
but the same thing is presumably true in
republican states down south which again
are gaining population
four northern states with democratic
governors that president biden won in
2020 illinois michigan pennsylvania and
new york will each lose a single
congressional
seat ohio will lose one seat in congress
that's the only
actual red state that lost a seat so far
as i'm aware the data released monday
was better for the democrats than
expected
earlier census bureau estimates had
suggested congressional gains in florida
and texas would be even bigger
the margins in certain states that
determined the final congressional
account were razor thin
new york lost a seat because of a
shortfall of only 89 people so thank you
to hero
of the republic governor andrew cuomo
the greatest of all governors it turns
out that
killing your own population as well as
raising taxes making life basically
unlivable in your state
led to the loss of a congressional seat
in your state
the release marked the start to a
constitutionally mandated effort to
redraw congressional districts across
the country
in advance of the 2022 election a
tangled litigious process likely to
benefit republican office holders more
than democratic ones next year
frankly if republicans don't regain the
house in 2022 given
joe biden's performance given the fact
that they are the out-of-power party
in an off-year election and given the
fact that republican states are gaining
seats
in in the in the census bureau
reapportionment
if they somehow fail to regain the house
in 2022 that is an act of
extraordinary incompetence and this is
not a secret i've told
as many republican legislators as i can
find and that's many of them since i
recently spoke at the at a republic a
house republican caucus
meeting i told them if you guys don't
retake the house in 2022 frankly you all
should lose your jobs
because this is a target rich
environment politically for you
joe biden is running up massive debt
massive deficits he's proposed 10
trillion dollars in spending this year
so far
okay so you guys you have a lot of room
to run here
all of this is a stark threat to
democratic control of the house which
will rest on a seven-vote margin with
four outstanding vacancies once newly
elected representative troy carter
democrat of louisiana takes office
in the coming weeks the results show
that the country grew over the past
decade by the second slowest rate in
history owing to an aging population
decreased fertility and slowing
immigration a slightly lower rate of
growth was recorded between 1930 and
1940.
so the the downturn thanks to covid
covet itself which killed off a lot of
people
the fact that people aren't having
babies particularly in urban centers
what this is leading to
is a is a slowing of growth in the
united states which actually is a
serious problem for a country that
continues to take on debt
that there will be no one alive to pay
right now the redistricting landscape is
of heavy advantage to republicans there
are many many states where republicans
control the state legislature
and redistricting is going to happen in
those states that includes places like
ohio west virginia north carolina
florida
and texas we're still not going to know
the partisan effect of the shift because
states have to sift through the
population data
it's going to be fun to hear from the
media how republican redistricting is
super racist and terrible but democratic
redistricting is wonderful and enjoyable
republican control of the redistricting
process in states
like texas florida north carolina
according to the washington post
is likely to increase the number of
congressional contests where republicans
have a chance of winning
republicans will control line drawing
for 187 congressional seats over the
coming year
democrats control 75 seats the remaining
seats that need to be drawn will be
decided by independent commissions or
divided governments according to the
cook
political report mike thumb battleground
director for the national republican
congressional committee said
redistricting favors republicans
it's not going to win back the majority
on its own but certainly it benefits
republicans
at this point all of which demonstrates
once again that when you govern your
states
like garbage people leave okay this is
the theme
the states that actually picked up in
total oregon one montana one colorado
one texas two
florida one and north carolina one the
states that lost seats new york
pennsylvania michigan ohio west virginia
illinois and california
that population shift is continuing the
midwest and the northeast are just
losing population
the south and the west are picking up
population except for california which
is losing population because it's
governed
like absolute garbage so well done
blue state governors you've done an
excellent job of driving people from
your states even though the media talk
about how wonderful you are it turns out
that
the people who live under you don't feel
the same way which is why so many people
have been leaving
and taking their votes and taking their
congressional seats and taking their
cash
and moving to states that are not
seeking to destroy their liberty
again there's a great hilarity to the
fact that new york lost to housing
because it came up 89 people short on
the census
my favorite part of that by the way is
that members of the new york delegation
were saying well you know if we just
kept recounting we'd certainly find 89
more people
weird because um i was informed that if
you did that with regard to votes that
was uh that was stealing the election
but if you do it with regard to census
bureau then i guess that that's good
just keep recounting until you get
exactly what you want
never forget guys it's all about cynical
power grabs meanwhile over in california
the the governor of california is now
officially going to be recalled gavin
newsom the garbage governor of
california we'll get to that in just
one second first if you run a business
you know you need to constantly make
your business better the way we make our
business better here at
daily wire is that we make sure that our
employees are the best and that means
adding the best employees
at ziprecruiter.com i would say a bunch
of the employees who work in this office
were received through ziprecruiter.com
and all of our employees know
that they could be replaced at a
moment's notice with ziprecruiter.com
which means that
everybody works super hard here at the
daily wire when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
top job sites with just
one click then zip recruiter's matching
technology finds people with the right
skills and experience for your job and
actively invites them
to apply in fact zip recruiter is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter had
a quality candidate within the very
first day
it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for their hiring needs so
while other companies overwhelm you with
way too many options zipper crew will
find you what you are looking for that
needle
in the haystack the diamond in the rough
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free
at this web address ziprecruiter.com
dailywire once again
remember to go to this unique place
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip recruiter is the
smartest way to hire
okay so california is about to put gavin
newsom on the ballot for recall
now it's still unlikely that he actually
gets recalled because it's a two-step
process first a majority of californians
who are voting have to vote for his
recall then he doesn't appear on the
recall ballot
then somebody else replaces him maybe
governor caitlyn jenner the first female
governor of the state of california
who ironically enough would be a man but
in any case an effort to recall
california governor gavin newsom
according to the huffington post
officially qualified for the state's
ballot on monday
thrusting him into a fight for his job
midway through his first term in office
to make it onto the ballot the
republican-led recall petition needed
signatures from just shy of 1.5 million
people
equal to 12 of the number of voters in
the last election for the office
supporters had until march 17th to meet
that threshold election authorities just
finished italian
in the end recall supporters submitted
1.626 million valid signatures
so again two questions will be asked
once you want to recall the governor and
if so who do you want to replace the
governor
some officials estimate it'll cost 400
million bucks for this recall to happen
newsom has wanted to run for president
for quite a while
but his handling of the covet 19
pandemic has been egregious they shut
down all the outdoor spaces they shut
down all the outdoor restaurants and
then he was eating indoors at the french
laundry
he's allowed homelessness to spiral
completely out of control in his state
he's allowed crime to spiral out of
control in his state
and now the people of california are
having second thoughts about the kendall
who is
gavin newsom so again we've been told by
the media that he's a wonderful governor
just like andrew cuomo is a wonderful
governor there's only one problem none
of these people are good at their jobs
and the way you can tell that none of
these people are good at their jobs is
that people are leaving
places like new york and california
again there's a reporting bias a
self-reporting bias when it comes to
polling
if you ask people in california if
they're happy with california many of
them
will say sure and then a lot of those
people be like also if i can get a job
in nevada i am gone
and the same thing in new york a lot of
people like yeah new york's the greatest
state it's the greatest state out here
and like oh wait the tax rate is way
lower in florida and the weather's
pretty nice most of the year
i'm gone i will catch you later people
act differently
than they say they do when it comes to
the polling data so take the census
bureau numbers pretty seriously and by
the way this trend is only going to
accelerate
the amount of movement into places like
florida is astonishing right now so
as folks in florida are fond of saying
don't new york they're florida don't
california
texas if you don't like what you had in
new york or california
leave that crap behind and move to a
free state that actually gives a damn
about your liberty
and also by the way that is interested
in protecting its own citizenry so all
this is being exacerbated by a federal
government by a democratic party that is
eager to exacerbate problems that exist
particularly in the blue states red
states are resisting a lot of the
mandates that are being
crammed down by the by the democratic
government right now
but blue states are just going to go
right along with it it's going to make
these places a lot
worse places to live i'm going to take a
couple
lifestyle issues here that really do
matter because one is is
actual legal changes that are being
pushed by the democratic government and
one is a sort of attitudinal change that
has taken over in blue states and it's
why people are leaving it's why people
are fleeing it's why people feel
uncomfortable
so begin with the legal right now there
is a hard push
by the left by the democratic party to
basically destroy policing across the
united states
the way that they do this is by cramming
down consent decrees on police
departments without any serious evidence
that those police departments have
actually
have acted in racist ways instead what
they do is they look at stats and like
oh well it looks like you're pulling
over as many black people
so i guess that we're going to have to
cram down a consent decree on you
and these police departments because
they do not have the resources to
actually resist
the federal government the doj has an
enormous budget these police departments
compared to the doj
when it comes to their legal budget not
close if the federal doj comes after you
and threatens you with civil rights
violations
then you are simply going to have to
sign a consent degree we saw this happen
in seattle
during the obama administration and 20
other cities during the obama
administration
eric holder's doj was used as a club
wielded against major metropolitan
police departments the predictable
result
is that the police were not able to do
their jobs and crime started to rise in
many of america's biggest cities well
the same thing is already happening the
murder rate is up some 30
in 34 of america's largest cities over
the course of the last year
the solution to that would be to you
know allow the police to do their job
and actually add police officers instead
the democrats and the media are firmly
on the side of destroying
police all over the country and they are
using individual cases as a lever
in order to destroy those police
departments so for example
the justice department has now announced
that it wants to investigate louis
the louisville police practices in
kentucky after briana taylor's fatal
shooting now
i talked about the brianna taylor
shooting what the facts in the brianna
taylor shooting tend to show
is that there was a legal warrant that
was taken out
for the apartment where brianna taylor
was staying
it was served not with a no knock
warrant believe it or not it was served
with a knocking warrant that was changed
on the day of
the police officers by their own
testimony knocked on the door repeatedly
they then entered the apartment when
nobody answered the door
and brianna taylor's boyfriend proceeded
to shoot one of the cops in the leg
actually hit him in the femoral artery
apparently the cop went down
there was a bunch of gunfire and brianna
taylor was killed
in the crossfire tragedy terrible
she was not the target of the
investigation she's not the target of
the warrant
but there is no criminal activity
certainly any no racist criminal
activity
by the cops here they were fired upon
they returned fire she got caught in the
crossfire the person who actually should
be blamed for brianna taylor's death
is the boyfriend who is the subject of
the drug warrants and who also happened
to be firing a gun at the police
officers
okay but the brianna taylor case which
has ended with
as far as i'm aware no indictments at
this point a federal investigation which
has ended with no actual indictments in
that case
they are using the brianna taylor case
as a lever in order to investigate the
entire louisville police department and
they do this over and over and over the
democratic doj
democratic doj is in fact a weapon on
behalf of democratic policy making
for all the talk about how attorney
general william barr was a was a
partisan hack who was working for trump
barr's partisanship did not extend to
becoming
trump's lackey in a wide variety of
areas eric holzer literally called
himself barack obama's wingman and now
merrick garland
who was almost on the supreme court for
goodness sake merrick garland
is basically now just using the power of
the doj to crack down on police
departments
without any evidence that the inciting
incident was actually an incident of
racism
or even deep police misconduct attorney
general garland announced monday the
justice department will open a civil
investigation
of the louisville metro police
department 13 months after the shooting
death of brianna taylor
a black woman whose killing was among
the flash points that sparked mass
social justice protests across the
nation last summer
garland said the federal pattern or
practice probe will seek to determine
whether the louisville police have
engaged in systemic abuses and unlawful
tactics with little accountability
marking the second time in five days he
has sought to use federal power to
examine a local law enforcement agency's
use of deadly force
so in the aftermath of the george george
floyd killing he announced that there
would be a doj investigation of the
minneapolis police department
sounds like a great idea considering
that minneapolis crime has spiked
minneapolis police department officers
are are quitting
and you will see this happen over and
over anytime there's a controversial
event
the doj will immediately step in and use
its power in order to cram down a bunch
of consent decree nonsense on police
departments that make it more difficult
for cops to do their jobs
and lead to cops quitting the force
here's merrick garland announcing he's
going after the louisville police
department on the basis of a case
which really did not violate criminal
statute
the justice department is opening us
opening a civil investigation
into the louisville jefferson county
metro government
and the louisville metro police
department
to determine whether lmpd engages in a
pattern or practice
of violations of the constitution or
federal law
the investigation will assess whether
lmpd
engages in a pattern or practice of
using unregu
un reasonable force okay now here's the
question
normally when the doj launches an
investigation you don't hear anything
about it
right when there's the doj investigation
to hunter binding you didn't hear
anything about it for several years
the doj launching an investigation is
not newsworthy the doj bringing
indictments is newsworthy so what is the
purpose of launching an investigation
the purpose of openly announcing that
you're launching an investigation into a
police department
is to generate the political the
political capital to go after the cops
that's what it's about you think that
what do you think are the chances the
merrick garland
launches an investigation into the
louisville kentucky pd and then turns
around goes you know what we
investigated everything's fine
how do you think that's gonna go of
course this is driven toward pressuring
the louisville pd
into signing some sort of false
confession about how racist and terrible
they are
and changing their practices and
procedures in line with what joe biden
and merrick garland would like
or even worse the people who work for
merrick garland who are going to include
several serious racial radicals by by
their own
records justice department officials say
that the louisville investigation will
be separate from an ongoing
criminal civil rights probe into
taylor's death the broader civil
investigation garland said will seek to
determine whether the city's police
force engages an unreasonable force on
constitutional searches and seizures and
unlawful executions of search warrants
on private homes we'll also examine how
louisville police tactics affect
racial groups ah there we go so bottom
line is
that what they're going to do is they're
going to look at equal outcome
they're not going to look at underlying
criminal activity they're going to say
well the population of louisville is x
the percentage of arrests is y
therefore the police department is
racist by the way
they've been doing this for years in
major metro police departments and it
leads to really bad outcomes
i've talked to cops for example who are
who were in the washington dc police
force
and what they were told is that they
were deliberately informed
that they could not write too many
tickets to black motorists that if they
gave too many tickets to black motorists
this would be perceived as systemic
racism
and so instead the cops would simply
look for white motorists to have tickets
to
so they could artificially boost the
stats there okay this is what you end up
with when
the only thing that matters is not
underlying individual criminal activity
the only thing that actually matters
is the racial constitution the racial
constituency rather
of particular cities and the racial
constituency of the people who are
arrested
well the problem here is that obviously
police officers just are not going to do
this police officers
are not going to involve themselves here
the democrats are making life worse in
major cities by targeting the cops it is
indeed that simple
karen bass democrat of california she
says we have to find a way to
hold officers accountable so they will
stop shooting people it's just
incredible this this lie
that the officers are willy-nilly
shooting people they're about a thousand
police shootings a year the vast
majority are people who are not black
about 250 people who are black are shot
by the cops every year less than 20
are shot unarmed by the cops even in
many of those cases the shootings are
not unjustified
it'll be for example where somebody is
trying to ram a cop with a car
that person is technically unarmed okay
so
the notion that the cops are running
around there are some there are hundreds
of
literally hundreds of millions of police
interactions with civilians every single
year
but karen bass believes that the police
are going around shooting people
willy-nilly which is of course why you
require justice department cram downs on
police departments all over the country
we have to find a way to hold officers
accountable
so they will stop shooting people you
know for example we need to spend a lot
more time
resources and emphasis on de-escalation
training
many officers i've talked to have said
when they go through training
they spend very little time a few hours
on de-escalation
but an awful lot of time on of course
how to protect yourself
but when you shoot that you shoot to
kill you don't shoot to a woman
okay i i don't know she's repeated this
in so many interviews that you're
supposed to shoot to wound i don't
like the tremendous ignorance it takes
to even say that is truly
astonishing and we all know the pressure
campaigns are being brought to bear
against the cops in cities all over the
united states
as i've said before we are now living in
a situation in which we have the
the complete bigotry of no expectations
that any time there's a controversial
shooting
we have to please the mob standing
outside as opposed to going through the
legal process
so the latest example of this comes
courtesy of elizabeth city north
carolina
mayor betty parker of elizabeth city
north carolina according to charlotte
pence bond writing for the daily wire
declared a state of emergency on monday
before body camera footage was released
of a shooting involving a deputy and a
42 year old black man
that happened last week and sparked
protests in the city over the weekend
so we are now preemptively declaring
states of emergency
in metropolitan areas before body cam
footage is released because of the
expectation
there will be riots if people don't like
what they see on the body cam footage
okay if you are expecting that a
population is going to engage in mass
criminal activity
because the police officers did
something controversial and body cam
footage is released
before the legal process is taking place
this is called the bigotry of no
expectations
in the declaration the mayor parker she
said in order to ensure the safety of
our citizens and their property
city officials realize there may
potentially be a period of civil unrest
within the city
following the public release of that
body camera footage parker directed all
departments and agencies of elizabeth
city to take whatever steps necessary to
protect life and property
public infrastructure and provide such
emergency assistance teams necessary to
preserve
public safety on wednesday andrew brown
jr a 42 year old black man was
reportedly killed following an encounter
with law enforcement authorities as
reported by the ap
pasqua tank county sheriff tommy wooten
the second has said deputies shot and
killed brown while serving drug related
search and arrest warrants but released
few other details
an eyewitness said deputies fired shots
at brown as he tried to drive away
and a car authorities removed from the
scene appears to have multiple bullet
holes and its back windshield
shattered so we don't actually know what
happened here yet the body cam footage
presumably
will be released and then we'll all know
whether the police engaged
in an act of brutality we still don't
know even if they did whether that has
anything to do with race
or racial differentiation again the
doj's case against these police
departments is based
on a presumption of racism that has yet
to be proved
just like in the chauvin case he was
convicted not just of the charges of
which he was convicted but a broader
charge of racism which was never even
alleged
the minneapolis police department has
been accused of racism again without
evidence
america more broadly has been accused of
racism without evidence okay so here's
the thing the predictable effect of all
this is making life worse
democrats nationwide are making life
worse based on their desire to trash the
cops
they're making a a higher crime america
they are creating a belief that it is
perfectly okay
to riot and loot more generally that
this is just a form of
acceptable social outreach when
something goes wrong in american public
life
there are other people who live in these
cities and there will be a backlash if
they're living in north carolina the
backlash will be electing presumably a
republican governor of north carolina
and if they're living in a blue state
and they feel no hope whatsoever that
the situation is rectified
people will just leave they'll take
their stuff and they will go to florida
and that is what we have been seeing so
that is the sort of
official push that's been coming from
blue state america that's leading to
leading
to people leaving these states and then
there's the soft social push
and again this is this is being pushed
at the federal level it's being pushed
in the media
there's a feeling that the culture in
which you stew the culture in which you
live the milieu that surrounds you
in blue states is becoming increasingly
difficult to live with
that there is a group of people out
there who celebrate each time somebody
who thinks
like you each time somebody who does not
move along with the woke mob is
destroyed those people surround you
i can tell you those sorts of feelings
do drive people to take action one of
the reasons we left california was not
just because of the exorbitant tax rates
and the
problems of homelessness and crime that
were plaguing the area that we were
living in
one of the reasons that my family left
california was the feeling that we were
surrounded by people who would be happy
to watch us burn politically
the feeling that there would be a move
that everything cultural would end
in politics and so the move against
synagogues and churches would grow
stronger
and then within five to ten years there
would be a move by the state government
of california to crack down on my
ability to raise my children as i see
fit or send them to a synagogue that
believes what i believe or send them to
a school that believes what i believe
all of the cancer culture stuff all the
the cultural attempts to destroy the
lives and careers of people
who you disagree with all that does have
an impact it makes people ideologically
sort
it makes people want to move to
communities where they don't feel like
they are under assault
all the time and yet the left is pushing
that assault and it doesn't have to come
from government it can come
within the culture to take a perfect
example
levar burden right just a cultural
figure the reading rainbow guy right a
unifying public figure
he's the guy who used to read us books
when i was a kid on pbs well now he's
appearing on the view
and explaining that cancel culture is
actually good because it's
accountability culture
okay so here's my question would you
want to live next to people who think
like levar burton
really you're let's say you're a
republican or a conservative or even a
moderate maybe you're even just a
moderate liberal who doesn't believe all
of the things the woke left are saying
and you're afraid of living next to
people who think like levar burton
you're fine with living next to anybody
but you're not willing to live next to
somebody
who is happy to watch your life ruined
if you say the wrong thing but here's
levar burton talking up exactly that
sort of idea
in terms of cancel culture i i
i think it's misnamed that's a misnomer
i think we have a consequence culture
and that consequences are finally
encompassing everybody
in the society whereas um they haven't
been
ever in this country so um i think i
think that
there there are good signs that are
happening in the culture
right now and i think it has everything
to do with a new awareness on people who
were simply
unaware of the real nature of life in
this country
for people who have been othered since
this nation began
okay so he's saying this with great
sincerity you know this is their
consequences to
to hurting people well what if you don't
hurt anybody what if it turns out that
the aggressive nature
of the of the woke mob makes life rather
unlivable
in many areas and then it's projected
out into the media landscape and
repeated
by people who should know better in the
media
and agreed with by all the people in the
major cities in these blue states
it makes people want to move it makes
people want to leave
we are creating a worse culture and
people want to escape that culture and
find a place
where they don't feel like they are
under assault from this sort of stuff
day in and day out
i'm going to give you the best example
i've ever seen of this in just one
second it truly is the best example
of the woke mob coming after somebody
just in the most vicious possible way
that i've ever seen
and again this sort of stuff does have
consequences for how people live in the
decisions that they make
get some more of this in just one second
first if you've got a medical issue
there's no reason to wait around on it
you should solve a medical issue because
those things tend to get worse over time
and not better well if you've got
something that is
nagging and annoying something like
erectile dysfunction why not just go get
it solved
i know you don't want to talk to a
doctor about it it feels embarrassing
but here's the thing you can do it
quickly and discreetly and inexpensively
by heading on over to roman with roman
you get a free online evaluation and
ongoing care 4ed all from the comfort
and privacy of your home
a us licensed healthcare professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate
it ships to you free with two-day
shipping the whole process is
straightforward and discreet
getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com ben and complete an online
visit
take care of your ed without leaving
your home complete an online visit today
to connect with a healthcare
professional
and get it taken care of head on over to
getromand.com right now you get 15 bucks
off your first month
it's really time to take care of your ed
remember get started today you'll save
15 bucks on your first order
of ed treatment that's getroman.com ben
you got a medical problem no reason to
wait on it instead go get it taken care
of go get it fixed right now
get roman.com ben you get 15 bucks off
your very first month of ed treatment
okay in just one second we're going to
talk about
the best example of the the woke mob
coming for somebody
in a despicable way that i think maybe
you've ever seen first
join us tomorrow for a special episode
of backstage we'll be watching joe
biden's first
congressional speech live his fake state
of the union apparently it's invite only
we'll be giving our analysis in real
time which just sounds awful
it sounds terrible i'm so pissed i have
to do this but
let my suffering be your joy head on
over to dailywire.com as nancy pelosi
says joe biden is expecting to share his
vision
for addressing the challenges of this
historic moment
so you know you can't miss it and by the
way there's always a certain level of
suspense as i've said before watching
joe biden speak for more than five
minutes
is sort of like watching nick willenda
walk over a volcano so you never know
what you could be watching
it streams tomorrow 8 30 p.m eastern 7
30 central on dailywire.com
and on our youtube channel daily wire
again if i'm going to be there you
should be there too i demand it
also another high energy episode of
candace is coming at you this friday
this week
canada's host political commentator and
interviewer dave rubin where they will
have a lot to
discuss including the recall election of
california governor gavin newsom and his
brand
new opponent caitlyn jenner yeah that's
it that's the thing that's happening
because we live in an alternative
reality subscribe now stream candace
live on fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 p.m
central only on daily wire get 25
off a new membership with code candace
at dailywire.com
subscribe make sure you grab the audio
podcast on apple spotify wherever
your platform of choice maybe just head
on over to apple podcast for spotify
subscribe to candace today be sure to
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
now when we moved our company from
california to tennessee i can tell you
it's like everybody sort of took
a deep breath a sigh of relief same
thing when i moved my family from
california to florida and one of the
reasons
is because we had self-selected into an
area
where more people were not going to be
savagely looking for our destruction
well online that's what people do and
this has become a national issue
and so people are looking for places
where they don't feel like they're going
to be destroyed every day so this is the
best example of something like this i've
ever seen it really is amazing so tariq
nasheed
who is just a terrible person the sort
of pseudo journalist
i've been a number of twitter fights
with him because he's just not a good
human being
so he tweeted out a video it now has
three million views
and here's how he described it a white
holiday inn express worker has a nervous
breakdown after he got scolded by a
black customer because of a mistake in
the reservation system
so if you just read that what you would
imagine is here is a white employee
who's having a nervous breakdown because
he's a racist right
we got we gotta we gotta torment we
gotta torment this guy because probably
he's a racist
okay now this video is super hard to
watch i'll describe it for for people
who are listening
because it really is very difficult to
watch this is a person pretty obviously
the person behind the counter
who has pre-existing mental issues right
this is perfectly
obvious just from watching the video you
can tell this is true right
and it turns out that now there is a it
turns out that now
there is uh the guy has has apparently
come out on reddit and explained who he
is he said that he has
borderline personality disorder and
schizo and
and some some schizoid tendencies
apparently according
to his reddit he says he has
schizoaffective disorders as well
okay so there are a lot of people who
are speculating that he might have some
sort of um
some borderline autism or something like
that in any case whatever the mental
condition is very obvious this guy has a
mental condition
and according to this guy apparently the
person who was filming him
not only was harassing him but called
him the f word for gay people
and turns out the guy's gay so just a
wonderful example
of an anti-racist warrior really making
life better for everybody by targeting
this employee now let me just ask you
if you've ever dealt with a person at a
hotel who hasn't been wildly
wildly competent right a person who's
trying to deal with a problem having
trouble dealing with the problem
if you're the person who harasses that
person and puts it on tape you're the
jackass
it's that simple and if you are the if
you are the person
who is at the airport harassing the
stewardesses you're the bad person
if you are the person who is at the
hotel harassing the guy behind the desk
because the computer's screwing up
you're the bad person but in our new
reality tariq nasheed makes you a hero
if you are black and the person behind
the counter is white because that person
must be a racist
for starting it up tight if you treat
them badly this is one of the saddest
videos i've ever seen
it went completely viral and if tariq
nasheed out his way this guy's life
would be destroyed right now
here is the video why did you get mad
and hit the computer
i'm sure you're on camera right yeah i'm
gonna shoot you on camera
okay the guy is actually punching his
own face and now he's ramming his head
into the computer screen so this is the
type of
people that are here working here and
and he's breaking down
[Music]
he says i've got to go
he says you're ruining my whole life
yeah and then he goes in the other room
and you can hear him crying and yelling
okay who's the bad guy here
is the guy behind the counter or is the
person who's filming this or is it tariq
nasheed who posted this online
it's not the guy behind the counter
everybody has bad days
hey forget about whether you're mentally
ill or not mentally ill every single
human being you know has bad days
you can either be the person who's
forgiving about people having bad days
or you can be the person
who's a jackass you can be the person
who seeks to destroy somebody's life
even the person who trolls twitter for
people who have made inappropriate
comments or a joke you didn't like
and then you can try and wreck them you
can find the person
who was having a crappy day and made a
bad comment at a supermarket and you can
tape them you can put them on tape you
can wreck their life
see social trust relies on us being able
to be at least somewhat forgiving with
one another
and understand that human beings are
sinful and that human beings are
vulnerable and then human beings say bad
things to one another all the time
and if you're a good person you let a
lot of that stuff go because you have
sympathy for other human beings
i i was at a an event in the not too
distant past and i was talking to this
one guy and he was obviously very drunk
uh and he and he came up and he made
what i thought was
kind of an anti-jewish reference and he
was very very drunk
and at that point i thought to myself
okay well i can turn this into a
confrontation
or i could take out my camera and i i
here's the truth i didn't even go
through this calculation i just figured
the guy's drunk he's having a bad day
and you know what he was drunk and he
was probably having a bad day
i didn't ruin his life it would have
been appropriate for me to ruin his life
but we live in a culture that prizes you
you are a hero if you ruin somebody's
life we are we live in a culture
where if you are a student in high
school and you post a video of yourself
celebrating getting your provisional
driver's license and you quote a rap
lyric using the n-word
a member of your class will take that
video and then they will hold it over
your head for several years and then
destroy
your dreams by sending it to the
university where you have just been
admitted
and getting you thrown off the
cheerleading team and then getting it
thrown out of the university
and then you'll get a feature piece in
the new york times about how brave and
wonderful you were
so how do you think people react to that
sort of thing how do you think people
react
they leave they say i don't want to live
in an area where people act like this
i don't want to be around people who act
like this
not with regard to race or ethnicity or
any other immutable characteristic i
don't want to live around people who are
this unforgiving
and this nasty people who are not going
to treat me like a fully rounded nuanced
human being who's never allowed to have
a bad day
now one of the things that uh i was
recently watching this michael jordan
documentary and there's this fascinating
part of the documentary is the last
dance on netflix
uh and uh there's a fascinating part of
the documentary where
michael jordan is in his hotel room and
the cameraman's in there with him they
say you know michael you basically own
the city why are you sitting around the
hotel room he says you understand every
time i leave this hotel room there are
cameras on me and i have to be on
now as somebody who's fairly well known
i have a little bit of the same thing
right when i'm
outdoors when i'm at parties i have to
be on right i have to know that somebody
is probably filming me at all times it's
very tiring
okay but i chose my career i chose what
i do for a living
the problem is this is now applied to
every single human every single human
feels like they always have to be on
that is exhausting it's very tiring it
is because it means that you have to be
watching what you say
all the time you're afraid you're gonna
make a joke you're afraid you're gonna
make a reference somebody's gonna grab
it somebody's gonna post it and then
your life is ruined and your family's
life is ruined your kid's life is ruined
or alternatively you could live in a
community that has a baseline level of
trust and that baseline level of trust
is
a little bit of forgiveness a little bit
of flexibility in what people say and
what people do
and understanding that somebody can be
having a bad day and it doesn't make
them a bad person
that somebody can say something
inappropriate and it could be accidental
or it could be
something slipping or it could be a just
a bad tendency that the person has but
they happen to be out of control that
day
and that the best response to that is
not to publicly shame that person and
ruin their life but maybe to go to them
privately
and say you know that was really hurtful
and you shouldn't have said that
the lack of forgiveness in our society
is leading people to find more forgiving
communities
now i have some faith that there will be
a re-uptick in religious affiliation
specifically because religious
affiliation does do this
it creates a feeling of unity inside
communities where
you are in the the hebrew phrase likely
to engage in dominican
clues right which means to see people
for their merits as opposed to see
people for their demerits but we're a
society that now
has this this levar burton-esque
accountability culture well i
have a question who are you to hold
anybody else accountable have you never
said anything
that you regret have you never tweeted
anything that regret have you ever had a
bad day
who do you want to be in that video this
is the question for you and for all of
america who do you want to be in that
video
do you want to would you rather be the
guy behind the counter or would you
rather be the guy who's in front of the
counter filming him
and mocking him or would you rather be
the person who doesn't have to deal with
any of that because they live in a
community where people treat each other
decently
the left which says that everybody has
to be treated nicely everybody's
identity
has to be has to be protected and
sheltered and their self-identification
has to be prized and cheered by society
that same left
will destroy you if they cross you they
will destroy you
if you disagree with them and so people
are sorting
a great sort is happening and
ideological sorting is happening in this
country
it's being exacerbated by national media
and it's going to happen
in every area of american life it's
going to happen in corporate america too
so for example simon schuster has now
had this massive problem
with hundreds of employees demanding
that there'd be no book deals for any
author tied to the
trump administration according to the
daily beast a petition submitted monday
asking simon schuster to stop publishing
books with former trump administration
officials gathered 216 signatures from
the company's employees
as well as several thousand from outside
supporters the petition asks that simon
schuster not treat the trump
administration as a quote unquote normal
chapter in american history
it also demands an upcoming memoir by
former vp pence be cancelled
saying it's legitimizing bigotry to even
allow people to read by pence's words
and they want the company to cut off its
relationship with the conservative
publishing house posthill press
postal press by the way is simply a
publishing house where
basically they select authors the author
is almost self-published
and then postal press uses simon
schuster just for distribution
and major publishers offer their
distribution services to small
publishing houses
so the predictable results of that good
for good for them
simon schuster they're saying we're not
going to do this right jonathan carp
put it down and put out a statement he
said we come to work each day to publish
not cancel
good for him we'll see how long he'll
last in that position but if this sort
of stuff continues you know what's going
to happen
people like us over at daily wire will
uncancel books we'll unburn books
right we'll take authors who have been
barred by the major publishers and we'll
pick them up here at daily wire and
we'll publish them
and the ideological sort will continue
right we'll we will see companies
finally make a decision
which side they want to be on and you
know what that's not a bad thing
maybe that's not a bad thing maybe the
accelerationist tendencies that we now
all have
let's just let this thing hit rock
bottom maybe that will actually bring
about some level of awareness
in the american public that they're
going to have to choose sides here one
good indicator
is there is a company called base camp
base camp
according to wesley yang of tablet
terrific writer
he says the base camp was reputed to be
the most aggressively woke company in
silicon valley
they have now announced that there will
be no more political conversations and
no more committees they said back to
basics back to individual responsibility
back to work
they put out a statement saying no more
societal and political discussions on
our company base camp account
today's social and political waters are
especially choppy sensitivities are at
11 every discussion remotely related to
politics advocacy or society at large
quickly spins away from pleasant you
shouldn't have to wonder if staying out
of it means you're complicit or waiting
into it means you're a target
these are difficult enough waters to
navigate in life but significantly more
so at work
it's become too much it's a major
distraction it saps our energy it
redirects our dialogue toward dark
places it's not healthy and it hasn't
served us well
we're done with it on our company base
camp account where the work happens
they also say that they are going to get
rid of committees they say no more big
working groups making big decisions or
putting forward formalized group think
recommendations no bureaucracy
or turning things back over to the
person or people who are distinctly
hired to make
these decisions say back to basics back
to individual responsibility back to
work
the big sort is happening and it's
happening in real time and it is not
going to be good for the democrats
it is really really bad for the
democrats
okay and you can see it happening in
hollywood as well right here at daily
wire we're starting to engage in the
business of making
film and tv content that you really
enjoy
that does not pay attention to the woke
standards well the american people are
ready for it
one of the reasons the american people
are ready for it is because hollywood
has decided that it hates you
the oscar ratings were down to fewer
than 10 million people tuning in
according to the new york times sunday
night's pandemic restricted telecast
from 58
fewer viewers than last year's record
low people are leaving new york
california and the oscars
according to brooks barnes and john
copeland for the film industry which was
already fighting to hold its place at
the center of american culture the
nielsen ratings for sunday night's 93rd
academy awards came as a body blow
only about 9.85 million people watched
the telecast a 58
plunge from last year's record low among
adults 18 to 49 the
oscars suffered an even steeper 64
decline
now the academy had been bracing for a
ratings drop because of the pandemic but
the reality is that between 1998 and
they lost some 30 million viewers on the
oscars that was before the pandemic
when you decide that you hate a huge
percentage of your neighbors it turns
out your neighbors don't want to hang
out with you either
hollywood is made perfectly clear it
does not like you it does not like
people who think like you
it does not tolerate people who think
like you you are the problem
and so people are saying you know what
i'm not willing to engage with you
and you can see democrats desperately
trying to backfill this democrats and
the media are desperately
trying now to undo what they have done
it's why for example you've seen in the
last couple of weeks
stacey abrams radically backpedaling as
fast as she could
possibly move backpedaling away from the
boycotts of georgia
because she finally realized that when
you castigate your fellow citizens as
racists who love jim crow they don't
like it and when you remove their
livelihoods on that basis they are
likely to vote out your friend rafael
warnock from the senate
george is about to turn red again thanks
to stacey abrams she helped turn the
state blue now she's about to turn the
state red again
and so she knows that so she's backing
away from that the media are trying to
help her out
apparently usa today appeared to have
bizarrely allowed retroactive edits of
an op-ed written
by stacey abrams an effort to water down
her previous justifications for boycotts
in a piece published on march 31st just
days before major league baseball
announced it was relocating its game due
to the backlash over georgia's election
reform bill that was signed into law
abrams seemed to defend the national
response to what she called the racist
classist legislation originally she
wrote the impassioned response to the
racist classist bill that is now the law
of georgia
is to boycott in order to achieve change
events hosted by major league baseball
world-class soccer college sports dozens
of hollywood films hang in the balance
at the same time activists urge
georgians to swear off of hometown
products to express our outrage
until we hear clear unequivocal
statements that show georgia-based
companies get what's at stake i can't
argue with an individual's choice to opt
out of their competition now you'll
notice the twitter over the last couple
days tried to lie and said that stacy
abrams opposed boycotts
what they said actually is that she
opposed the boycotts after mlb announced
the boycott
that's true because she freaked out and
she realized that they've gone too far
and they're going too far
okay she continued to sort of defend
these boycotts
okay well now the article was updated on
april 6th now
she says the impassioned and
understandable response to the racist
classist bill that is now the law of
georgia is to boycott in order to
achieve
change her revisions say rather than
accept responsibility for their craving
actions
republican leaders blame me and others
who have championed voting rights and
actually read the bill their full
outrageous design tied the fact they
prioritized making it harder for people
of color to vote
to add to the injury the failed former
president is now calling for
cancellation of baseball as the national
pastime
boycotts invariably also cost jobs
a revised op-ed adds quote instead of a
boycott i urge other events and
productions to do business in georgia
it's another backfilling desperately the
backfilling ain't gonna work
we all know what is going on here you've
created a culture that is unlivable for
a huge
swath of people you're creating
lifestyles that are unlivable for a huge
swath of people you're increasing crime
you're increasing homelessness you're
increasing taxes you're increasing
regulation
you're making life worse and people are
leaving your areas and leaving your
party
you may not believe that now because you
believe that you're always on the
upswing democrats have to
are invested in this this bizarre sort
of evidence-free optimism about their
political prospects going into the
future
they're about to get a lesson in reality
come 2022. alrighty we'll be back here
later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airs
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show